okay guys okay guys we are playing a new
game
this game is called new message it was
seeing it on the screen in a second it's
his [ __ ] doing this thing based on
episode of black mayor of season 3
episode 3 shut up and dance [ __ ] okay
it's fine and you find yourself on a
train late at night okay it's fine
um there's but one other person in okay
um he's nervous
often checking his phone alright it's
fine but he got off but forgot his phone
it's buzzing there's a new message let's
have this pitch out you got strangers
found
holy [ __ ] is it blurry this [ __ ]
thing see to bring up phone can't see
rude [ __ ] hole right mouse button to
interact
why am I so slow
okay how do you
[Music]
any [ __ ] state retro package is in
Oscar Street we'll be watching
okay hey Chitti here there ain't [ __ ]
anywhere no [ __ ] seats on these
things okay so I found it it's a lot
[ __ ] faster if you don't have her
phone out hug says blur how last hey
babe a [ __ ] dark eyes do this I guess
that [ __ ] dark a [ __ ] out here and
not the good [ __ ] Hobart Mouse for a few
second interact okay all right this is
the Dorothy Q Metro weird I gotta go
Oscar Street I'll be watching okay
where's Oscar straight
[ __ ] suspense allows music it's all I
get to say Oscars chases Oscar straight
what is that over there
is that how I need
hello sir oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] walking backwards can I help you
sir where are you going
packages in Oscar Street is there a
package here right here
package is in an oscar street is this
Oscar Street I don't [ __ ] know what
the [ __ ] is going on in this game okay
say this Oscar Street yeah
the package is I'm [ __ ] here so I've
been mislead I'll be watching
yeah package her on here hello sir I
should leave him alone alright [ __ ]
homeless it's over here talking dark in
here though
[ __ ] yeah I want to get [ __ ] weird in
here that's all I gotta say is this the
package death toll rises the crime scene
do not cross
okay any [ __ ] daddy
that death toll is about oh my god I
gotta get a new microphone my
microphones [ __ ] [ __ ] second chance
all I got to say Oscar Street so this is
Oscar Street where the [ __ ] is the
package set oh uh I got the brown
package okay mmm good place it over to
the park bench yeah you got it baby
you know that's me twice you know if I
see a money opportunity I see a money
opportunity this guy still sleeping you
know he's [ __ ] done
[ __ ] okay
packet boy head over to the warehouse
Ian in casanare E Street [ __ ] is Casa
nari straightened
that's [ __ ] up
Cassin area where the [ __ ] is that
over here
that guy's my straight self
warehouse where the [ __ ] is their
warehouse
yes yeah you know I could probably go
through that door now don't you to bet
so let's take a look and see what may be
going on over there you know what I'm
saying but just be twitching
it's locked [ __ ]
okay where the [ __ ] is cast no so you're
getting at the park or something the
warehouse on Cass the warehouse in
cassowary Street [ __ ] is that with the
[ __ ] bus
the [ __ ] cassowary straight sit over
here
don't [ __ ] signs anywhere
okay
guess I gotta [ __ ] just go around
until I find this [ __ ] tits Dorothy it
was not here I got to go back in the
subway I guess cuz I don't know where
the [ __ ] I'm gonna find a cache or a
street where the [ __ ] is the cassowary
straight no no no the [ __ ]
straightest I guess we got to go this
way something in that [ __ ] ah well I
really [ __ ] locked out there I almost
walked all the way in the [ __ ] subway
okay dad wake up this is much better
anyone ever walk black mirror is that a
good show I think that the first
episodes about like a [ __ ] a pig or
something I'm like a show I like [ __ ]
pigs used to have okay okay [ __ ] in
here [ __ ] went in there I know he dead
I know he dead
that [ __ ] was that holy [ __ ] this
paintball here
where's Castro Street so I guess I'm
just going in
warehouse warehouse now what is this can
I use this I'll they looking at me like
that
I don't like that alright let's say here
kasseri [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] is all this
leaving your phone behind is this a bag
Potter Shama
don't mind if I do do it try it
China [ __ ] it okay I got him whoa whoa
whoa whoa what we got him
okay
locked
are we [ __ ] terminated him wait what
a happy I sir a new cellphone Mantello
bertocchi
I can't get that gonna have yes sir his
eyes that's strong but gentle
alright let's go here let's go elevator
key I got that [ __ ] a in LeFay the
king yay oh yeah we're moving now babe a
we are movin now I know you know I'm
[ __ ] frozen what is that a mouse [ __ ]
jockstrap
so what I gotta do well anything
[ __ ] that where the sound go okay
gonna have you help us jump from up here
that is for me to know and also find out
the [ __ ] is this okay
the [ __ ] am i supposed to be doing
the [ __ ] was that
did anyone see that
he's hit the game tripping balsam jump
all right you say so the [ __ ] is going
on here
[Music]
Oh get the [ __ ] back in here
mmm it's good
I'll [ __ ] up they can't say saying I
look closely this time my taint
okay huh
whoa like that very weird record game I
recommend then it's on the cheer window
that's pretty interesting
[Music]
all right thanks for watching y'all hey
Sabbath he's out